Heidi is with us
Heidi is in Tampa hi Heidi welcome to
Dave Ramsey show hi Dave thank you I
have backed myself into a corner with my
student loans I originally borrowed
40,000 in 97 to go to school I started
out paying them and that was in and out
of four appearances as my now ex-husband
went to series of unemployment so I have
been a single mother I work three jobs
and the payment they want for me is
always more than I can pay so I
consulted with an attorney and it looks
to me like my best option right now is
to file chapter 13 which will interrupt
the garnishment that I now have on my
primary job and then then that will help
me the attorney says get in to get out
of default with it and get into a loan
repayment hopefully an affordable amount
that I can show you you've had them for
30 years yes I've tried to pay them and
I can the current balance to pay it off
is what Oh without current balance is
its balloons to a hundred and six
thousand and what do you make it your
day job my my tax return last year was I
brought home 52,000
mm-hmm and how old are your children 19
and 16 okay you're getting child support
no why I'm here there but I don't get it
officially on the record especially you
have 50 you said you made 52,000 yes and
and in Tampa Florida and what do you do
for a living
I work for a construction manufacturing
firm called Katara I'm the Quality
Manager there so you're doing 40 hours
there and then you're working extra jobs
too
yep I work as an admin for a restaurant
and you got work on the computer at home
at night and then I work weekends at my
kids here's the problem you're gonna run
into okay a chapter 13 is a five-year
plan it's 60 months and you pay payments
every month during the entire five years
and if you do not pay more than you've
ever paid in your life you're gonna come
out of the chapter 13 with debt with
substantial debt and so you know you
have the chapter 13 will get rid of the
garnishment that is true and it might
get you on a minimal payment to get you
where you can breathe but both of those
things are short-term fixes if you do
that you have to have a long-term answer
to this equation and so let's start
doing some math if we want to be rid of
a hundred thousand dollars in five years
it's 20 thousand dollars a year if we
want to be rid of a hundred thousand
dollars in three years it's thirty five
thousand dollars a year that's what you
need to do and that means you need to
think about what kind of a career you
can move you can make on your day job
but more importantly what kind of second
job you can get that's better than the
one you've got because I want you to get
your income up fifteen or twenty
thousand dollars and I want you to start
putting thirty five thousand dollars a
year three thousand dollars a month
towards these loans so that in three
years this 30-year curse on your life is
broken because you have swept this under
the rug and swept it under the rug and
swept it under the rug and you've had a
reason or an excuse every year that you
have not dealt with it and it is growing
as you have noticed it is not going away
student loans are not bankrupt able in
the sense that you can make them go away
with the chapter 7 bankruptcy the only
way you're going to get rid of it is pay
it chapter 13 will get you give you some
temporary relief and get allow you to
get situated but you need to think about
what we've got to do with our income
what we've got to do with our budget to
put $3,000 a month for the next three
years and break this 30-year curse off
of you I'm gonna help you you hold on I
want you to go through Financial Peace
University as my guest you need some
help and I'll help you
[Music]